Narrator:
Tonight, Anne Wojcicki,
the billionaire founder
of game‐changing
genetics company 23andMe,
returns to the Tank.
My son has also been watching
this show all the time.
If I don't come away
with a royalty deal,
I'll really be in trouble.
Hi, there, Sharks.
Our sales are on the rise,
and we are ready to
blast to the moon.
I don't think so.
What are your sales?
$3.5 million.
Ohh!       Ohh!
Ohh!                        Ohh!
Wow. Amazing.
We've sold out three times.
I think the product is genius.
[ Party horns honk ]
You guys are
the American dream team.
I'm a fighter.
It's very important
that you leave now.
♪♪
Narrator: First into the Tank
is a simple device
for a common problem.
♪♪
Ohh.
Hi. I'm Becca.
And this is my daughter,
Eve.
Hi, Sharks!
[ Laughter ]
And this is my mom.
Hi. I'm Barb.
I'm the grandma.
And we're all
from Houston, Texas.
We are here seeking $100,000
in exchange for 10% equity
in our company,
UnbuckleMe,
a small product that's making
a big difference for families.
Eve, do you want to
go get some ice cream?
Yes!
Okay!
I'm gonna get in the car.
[ Chuckles ]
When that little girl
was born,
my mom offered
to help me with childcare,
which was so helpful to me
as a working mom.
But there was a problem.
Okay, we're here.
Let's get you out.
Unbuckle me! Unbuckle me!
Honey, honey, I'm trying.
I'm trying.
Ohh, this arthritis in my thumb,
it's hard.
She could not unbuckle
my daughter's car seat.
Turns out child car seat
buckles
require 9 pounds
of pressure to release.
It was not safe
for her to take my daughter
out in the car,
but I needed her help.
I don't know
what I'm gonna do!
Try this!
It's called UnbuckleMe.
You just slide it
around the buckle...
position the peg over
the red button...
and pinch the ends together.
Whoo‐hoo! You're free.
That was easy.
Hop out.
[ Laughs ]
Let's get some ice cream.
[ Chuckles ]
There you go.
[ Laughter ]
Is it good?
UnbuckleMe
is a patented tool
that uses a type‐2 lever
to reduce the force
to unbuckle a child's car seat
by more than 50%.
It's a simple machine.
It does not attach to
the car seat for safety
and should be kept out of reach
of kids when not in use.
UnbuckleMe gives me
the confidence
to know I can always
safely buckle my granddaughter.
Who wants to help us make
traveling with kids in car seats
easier and safer?
We have some samples
to show you how it works,
but first,
we'll say bye to Eve.
‐Bye, Eve.
‐Bye, Eve!
‐Bye!
‐Eat your ice cream.
So, all of you have a sample
of the buckle
that is most commonly used
on car seats today,
and you have a sample
of UnbuckleMe.
First, we're just gonna try it
without our product.
You start by putting
your hand underneath it
and then pushing, 'cause
if you had a child in there,
you wouldn't want to
push on the child.
What I want you to do is see
that it is difficult
and that it does take
9 pounds.
Or if you have nails,
that's a problem.
Davison: Exactly.
Exactly.
Well, see, exactly.
We'll get to that.
So, you slide the white part
underneath the bottom
of the buckle.
How far do you slide in?
You slide it
so that the post is centered
in the center
of the red button.
Then use the other hand
and put a couple fingers
underneath the white part,
press down
on the end of the black
so that you're
using leverage...
Oh, wow.
Yeah.
...and pull down forward.
That's night‐and‐day
different.
Isn't it?
What percentage of the people
that, you know,
have car seats
actually need to use this?
'Cause this isn't
a problem for everybody.
Correct.
Well, so, I'll tell you.
About half of our sales
come from grandparents.
There are 70 million
grandparents in the U. S.
My mom's an occupational
hand therapist,
so she can give you
some statistics
that a third of women
in their 50s and 60s
have arthritis.
What I'm trying to get
is size of market.
Because, A, you have to have
a child that's in a car seat.
That's right.
B, you have to have issues
with 9 pounds of pressure
on a red button.
So, let me ‐‐
So, smaller market,
smaller market,
smaller market.
Totally follow you.
So, there's 12 million car seats
sold every year.
So, grandparents is about
half of our sales,
but let me tell you
why the market gets bigger.
30% to 40% of our sales
are actually
to younger families
who are buying this
for what we call
the "school drop‐off
line scenario."
They're actually handing it
to the second or the third row
to a 4‐ or a 5‐year‐old
to unbuckle ‐‐
they can unbuckle
themselves,
hand it back to Mom or Dad
in the front seat,
keep it out of reach.
Carpool line moves faster.
They don't have to get out of
the car, they don't have to
break their shoulder
trying to reach to the kid.
It's stressful being
in a carpool line.
Interesting.
The challenge ‐‐
the unfortunate consequence,
perhaps, is that
they're moving them
into booster seats
too early,
and I'm a child passenger
safety technician,
so I am all involved.
So that's your background.
You're a child passenger
safety technician?
We're the perfect
team, Mark.
The dream team!
[ Chuckles ]
Becca, $100,000 for 10%...
Yes.
...imputes it's worth
a million smackeroos.
That's correct.
Now, why is it worth
a million smackeroos?
So, let me tell you about
some of our numbers, Kevin,
'cause I know that's
what you want to hear.
I'm ready, Becca.
Alright.
Bring it on.
Been on the market
for 22 months.
We've sold
over 35,000 units.
Our total sales
are $400,000.
How much do you
sell them for?
We sell them for $14.99.
$14.99. Okay.
That's right.
And what do you make them for?
$1.80. We currently
manufacture in the U. S.
John: Nice.
And how are you
acquiring customers?
So, we are relying largely on
Facebook ads and on Amazon ads.
We're spending about $3
to acquire a customer.
We think we can get even lower,
closer to 2.
Does this have a patent,
or can I ‐‐
We do.
We have two patents.
Issued?
We have a utility and ‐‐
Issued.
An issued utility
and design patent.
You have answers, Becca,
I must say.
I have all the answers,
Kevin.
Yeah, I'm impressed.
You guys are the American
dream team, right?
We are.
You're exactly why people
watch this show,
because they want
to have that idea,
they want to come on
and be on that carpet
with 22 months of sales.
Hey, thanks!
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
It's awesome.
I thought it was gonna be
frivolous and pointless,
but I am wrong, and you have
convinced me of that.
Kevin, that's the highest
compliment.
So I'll make it easy on you.
What you need is
great social media
to reduce your
customer‐acquisition cost.
Absolutely.
I've got a killer team that
does that, just killer.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
So...
Yeah.
I'm gonna give you
the $100,000.
I want a dollar
royalty on it.
But I'm not greedy
for the equity,
but I want what we call
"schmuck insurance."
So I'll do it for 7% equity.
Okay.
Alright?
A little discount there of 30%.
Lower.
Yeah. Little lower.
And I'll get a dollar a unit,
and my team goes nuts to get
your customer acquisition down.
‐How long's the dollar royalty?
‐For how long? Yeah.
‐In perpetuity?
‐It's forever, yeah.
In perpetuity, you have
to pay him a dollar...
Cuban: Perpetuity?!
for the rest of your life.
The word that you never
want to hear from Kevin.
Perpetuity.
If these Sharks want to make
a counteroffer, they can,
but you now have
a bona fide offer
from the only Mr. Wonderful
you're ever gonna meet.
♪♪
Narrator:
All Sharks are still in,
and Becca and Barb have
an offer from Kevin
for their car seat buckle
opening tool, UnbuckleMe.
I'm gonna give you the $100,000.
I'll do it for 7% equity.
Okay.
And I'll get a dollar a unit,
and my team goes nuts to get
your customer acquisition down.
How long's
the dollar royalty?
For how long? Yeah.
In perpetuity?
It's forever, yeah.
You now have a bona fide offer
from the only Mr. Wonderful
you're ever gonna meet.
I have to say, I'm pretty
impressed with you,
like, both of you,
and I can relate.
Davison: Thank you.
I do a lot of things
with my mom and my kids,
and so I kind of
love the team.
Thank you.
My son has also been watching
the show all the time,
and he loves royalty deals,
so if I don't come away
with a royalty deal,
I'll really be in trouble.
Okay.
Like, 23andMe, my company,
like, we do a ton
on social media,
and I think, you know,
we really connect also
with families,
and I can get the word out.
So I'm actually ‐‐
I'd love to entertain
a royalty deal with you.
I am reluctant
on the royalty,
and here's why ‐‐
especially given that we may
have to reduce our prices,
if we scale to market,
our profit might be
a dollar per unit.
Here's how we'll
solve your problem.
Yeah.
The power we have together
is ridiculous.
We'll split the deal.
We'll split it.
And we'll take
50 cents each.
It doesn't solve the problem
of the royalty.
Davison: It doesn't
solve the problem.
I may be giving you, Kevin,
100% of my profit in perpetuity.
Alright, alright. Listen.
Do you ‐‐
A fixed‐dollar amount.
I really can't.
Stop your whining.
Here's what we'll do.
After we recoup
our 100K back,
we'll drop the royalty
down to 50 cents.
[ Laughs ]
So, here's another
path for you, Kevin.
And let me tell you how you're
gonna get your money back.
How?
By the end
of this year,
we'll be 85% growth
over last year.
We're growing
5% month to month.
What are your projections
right now for the next year?
Year‐to‐date, $200,000.
By the end of the year,
we'll easily do $300,000.
We're cash‐flow positive,
as well.
I haven't even
mentioned that.
Okay, so we heard your feedback.
You don't want the perpetual.
But I think it is important for
us to recoup at least 100K,
so we'd want to keep it
at 50 cents.
And ‐‐ And up ‐‐
Yeah, but I want more
than 100K back.
No, 100%.
We keep it at 50 cents.
We want to get $250,000 back.
And then we want
the 10% equity,
so it'd be 5% each.
[ Laughs ]
Greiner: So you're raising how
much money you'd give them.
Royalty goes away.
The royalty goes away
at $250,000.
But think about this.
So, here ‐‐ [ Sighs ]
O'Leary: Can you imagine
the power we have together
in terms of social?
Are you kidding?
[ Whispering
indistinctly ]
It's great.
It's phenomenal, I'm sure.
We have a tremendous
amount to learn
from you Sharks on that.
It would be a lot of fun.
And I have to say, like,
I would lo‐‐
Like,
I love the family side.
I'm known for a big family.
Yeah.
Like, there's a lot
we could do.
It's just the royalty.
It's just, you know...
Yeah, but it's 250K.
Yeah, but I could be giving you
50 cent from every unit I sell.
That could be my entire
profit margin.
Well, Mark and I want to
throw in something.
Okay.
Bring it on.
You guys are wonderful.
Love you.
I mean, you're, like Mark said,
the real deal.
The American dream.
This is fantastic.
So, here's our offer.
Our offer is we're gonna
give you $100,000,
no royalty,
20% split between us.
‐Whoa.
‐Ohh.
‐That's it.
‐Wow.
‐20% will help you grow...
O'Leary: Oh, that's a lot
of equity.
Wojcicki: There, you're really
giving up a lot.
...will get you
where you need to go.
Let's see where your head's
at now, Becca.
And we're partnering ‐‐
Well, you're getting
two Sharks.
Giving up a lot.
You're getting two Sharks.
I'll give you the $100,000
for 15%, no royalty.
♪♪
[ Laughs ]
This is amazing.
Heilman: Ooh.
We never anticipated this.
This is wo‐‐
That's a phenomenal
offer.
It's a lot of equity
to give up.
So now you have
three offers
that you have
to decide on.
Yeah.
Would you split 15%
and we'll call it a deal?
Nope.
'Cause we're worth...
We're worth it, baby.
Wow, that's such greed.
Deal.
Deal!
Aah! Whoo! [ Laughs ]
‐Welcome to the Shark Tank.
‐Boom.
Ohh!
[ Laughter ]
But thank you so much
for your offer!
My son's coming after you!
‐Oh! Thank you!
‐Thank you so much!
Congratulations.
This is awesome.
Oh, my God.
I'm so glad
you decided...
You're such a smart cookie.
Mom, congrats.
Oh, gosh, Lori!
Thank you so much!
Well done.
You're an inventor.
Oh, it's gonna be so good.
You're an entrepreneur.
It's awesome.
Oh, thank you so much.
Give me the five.
You killed it.
Killed it.
Greiner: Amazing.
Becca,
it's over between us.
[ Laughs ]
Maybe I'll come back
with my next product.
I don't think so.
[ Laughter ]
Davison: We're so excited
with Mark and Lori.
We think they understand
our product,
they respect us
as entrepreneurs
and everything
we've accomplished so far.
They're ready to
jump on our team.
We are so excited to
have them on our team!
[ Laughs ]
♪♪
Narrator: Next up is a company
whose mission it is
to make computers
more accessible to everyone.
♪♪
Hello, Sharks.
I'm Brad Johnston.
I'm Lisa Love.
And I'm Greg Smith,
and we're from
San Francisco, California.
We are seeking $500,000
for 8% equity...
[ Groans ]
...in our company...
Together: Tanoshi!
Hey, Brad, what does
"Tanoshi" mean, anyway?
Thanks for asking,
Greg.
Tanoshii is
the Japanese word for "fun."
[ Party horns honk ]
[ Laughs ]
We named our company
Tanoshi
because we want kids everywhere
to be successful ‐‐
in school and life ‐‐
all while having fun.
Now, Sharks,
let's face it.
With all the crazy,
crazy content
on the Internet these days,
it's no wonder
parents are worried
about what their kids
might see online.
But in reality,
in order for kids to keep up,
they need technology
to develop the skills
for future success.
So, let us introduce you
to the Tanoshi 2‐in‐1,
a two‐in‐one
tablet and computer
preloaded with age‐appropriate
and educational content
where kids can do
their homework,
they can play games,
they can
even learn to code.
With our built‐in
parental controls,
parents can allow or deny
what their kids have access to.
And they can even see
how much time
kids are spending
on certain apps.
[ Laughter ]
Let's say
little 8‐year‐old Mark here
is spending a little
too much time on his Tanoshi.
Well, great news.
His mom can even
pause the device,
all from her smartphone.
Tanoshi provides peace of mind
for busy, busy parents,
knowing that their kid
is safer online.
Now, Sharks, our sales
are on the rise,
and we are ready to
blast to the moon.
So, tell us, who wants to
ride the rocket ship with...
Together: Tanoshi?
Nice job, guys.
Nice job.
Thank you.
It was a good one.
Guys, why wouldn't the iPad
put you to zero?
That's a great question.
We are less than half
the price of an iPad.
We are $199, all‐in.
That's a good price.
It includes
the parental controls,
all the apps, everything ‐‐
the device ‐‐
everything out of the box,
ready to go.
‐This is cool.
‐Thank you.
So, you sell it for $199.
What's your cost?
So, our landed cost, all‐in,
is close to $120.
$120? Oh, that's not
a lot of margin.
Electronics don't usually have
high margins, correct?
Yes, correct.
Yeah. Okay.
Computers in
the consumer electronics space
in retail today are usually
actually single‐digit margins.
Cuban: Right.
So we're actually
much stronger.
They're trying to sell
much larger volumes, too, right?
You're kind of
a niche market for kids.
Yeah.
So it's a harder sell.
But either way,
tell us about your sales,
where you're selling them,
and how it's going.
Okay, sure.
So, we've been on the market
for about a year and a half.
We've actually
already sold out
three times
in that first year and a half.
And what kind of volume?
Today, we have
$720,000 in sales.
Cuban: Okay.
I've been in consumer
electronics space for 15 years.
I started as a consultant,
and I actually helped some
pretty big‐name companies ‐‐
for example,
Dell, HP, Intel ‐‐
grow their retail sales.
I went to Toshiba.
Over there, I inherited
a half‐a‐million‐dollar‐a‐year
retail accessory business.
Within two years,
I grew that to $20 million.
So I skyrocketed that.
Wow.
I really enjoyed
doing that,
but I wanted to
own the product myself.
I wanted to be more
than a consultant.
I saw what was happening in
the little toddler tablet space.
It was just skyrocketing.
And it still is today.
And then we started
looking at
what's going on
in the education space,
and the really
"aha" moment for me
came from my mom
and my sister,
who teach in low‐income
neighborhood schools.
And what they told me was,
in third grade then,
you started taking
national standardized tests
on a computer,
and some kids
were actually struggling.
They didn't know where
the keys were on the keyboard.
And I said,
"This is terrible.
Just because
you're low‐income,
you shouldn't be put into
a less class,
a less track
for the rest of your life."
So we came out and said,
"We need to make
an affordable solution
that anyone can use."
John: Doesn't look like
you're gonna have a hard time.
I think
the product is genius.
Thank you.
Why are you here?
We need to raise capital.
As I mentioned earlier,
we've sold out three times.
Each time ‐‐
You absolutely don't,
because you know every maker,
and this is a clear, easy path
to licensing.
Cuban:
You can't license this.
License?
It's an integration play.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Mark's spot‐on.
Yeah.
We're an integrator.
So, what we do
as a company ‐‐
We're actually not even
a hardware company.
I'll be honest with you.
We're a software company.
What we do is we build
some customized software.
So, what customized software
did you build?
So, on this, we actually
don't have any of
our own software yet.
'Cause I didn't see any.
Yeah.
No. No, no.
And, again, it comes back to,
unfortunately,
the whole capital play.
Guys, look, you are in
the most competitive,
difficult space that there is.
You're competing against
some of the biggest companies ‐‐
in particular, Apple.
You know? And Samsung.
So, so ‐‐
And I 100% agree with you.
But keep in mind, I worked
for two of those companies.
Doesn't matter.
But the reason I didn't go
back to work for another one
is they're just building
commoditized products.
One question I always ask myself
when I part with my capital is
"How does it come home to Daddy?
How do I get it back?"
This goes all the way
back to Mark's point earlier
about these other
consumer electronic companies.
So, I've been around
long enough
to watch how other companies
get acquired.
It's a very difficult
market.
Selling 2,000, 5,000,
10,000 units on Amazon ‐‐
yes, I think you can.
But I think you need to
either reduce your costs
significantly
or raise your prices
at least 100 bucks a pop,
because you're not gonna be
100,000 to 200,000 units, right?
That's a challenge.
And so
for those reasons, guys,
I wish you the best,
but I'm out.
Brad, I hate the hardware space
you're in.
PC commodity business ‐‐
brutal.
You need capital to buy
razor‐thin margin product,
which I hate a lot.
I spent 15 years of my career
selling 6‐ to 12‐year‐olds.
The other thing
you're missing here
is customer acquisition costs.
Getting those kids
at the right time is hard ‐‐
very hard.
Yes.
It is difficult.
They have no credit cards,
those kids.
Greiner: [ Chuckles ]
Their parents do.
Johnston:
That is correct,
and so one thing
we're actually doing
and a big mission of us
is actually to move
more of our traffic
to buy off our website
so that when their parents buy
with their credit cards...
It makes so much sense to me
that you would approach ‐‐
...we can go sell them
additional software.
...you would approach
a large manufacturer
and license the whole thing
to them,
because you can make it happen
and take away the curse
of dealing with inventory
on thin‐margin hardware.
I'm out.
Have you put
your own money in this
or you have outside investors
now or...?
It's basically
my life savings ‐‐ $150,000.
I invested as much
as I possibly could into it.
Thankfully, I have
a very supportive wife.
Wow.
So, Brad, you're driven by
a bit of a social mission,
'cause you're all‐in,
right?
Yes. 100% in. 110%.
With any additional money
invested?
We've raised another $185,000
from friends and family,
and we've also borrowed a couple
hundred thousand dollars
to get the first
productions going.
[ Groans ]
Wojcicki:
I think it's an amazing mission.
I realize how difficult it is
to actually get
these types of things to kids.
Mm‐hmm.
I think it's a challenge.
I'm out.
You know, sometimes,
with certain things
where it's so competitive,
it's better to license.
And you could maybe even
sell yourself on the side.
A lot of people
think licensing means
you're giving
everything away.
It doesn't have to be.
You could do your own selling
under your own label
and then also license
to other people.
For me, I don't think
this is the right business.
I'm sorry. I'm out.
♪♪
Narrator:
Four Sharks are out.
Daymond is Brad, Lisa,
and Gregory's last chance
for a deal for their affordable
laptop for kids, Tanoshi.
John:
Okay, so, we're already talking
about why licensing
should be great,
and I think that, you know,
maybe you're only thinking
"Dell, Samsung, Apple,"
right?
But what I'm thinking is,
you never go
to number 1 and 2 operators
to do a deal with you.
You go to number 30
that wants to be number 1 and 2.
So, I would do
a deal with you.
I'd give you the $500,000.
It would be contingent
that we get a license.
I'd walk in the door with you.
We'd call everybody we can.
But I would do it for 20%.
Okay.
So, with that, would you be okay
if we continue with our brand?
Absolutely.
In addition
to the license.
Yeah, yeah. Absolutely.
You cannot say no to that.
O'Leary:
You got to take that deal.
Brad‐a‐tola,
take that deal.
[ Laughter ]
Greiner:
[ Laughing ] What?
Brings our valuation down
quite a bit.
No, it brings your business
quite up a bit.
Brad‐a‐tola?
It brings your upside
up a lot higher.
Brad, imagine if you were
unshackled from hardware
how fantastic
this pitch would be.
And then you'd be uncoupled
from this total commodity.
Can we ‐‐
Can we take a moment?
[ Whispering ] So, that's
one thing that we asked for.
♪♪
[ Whispering
indistinctly ]
♪♪
Okay.
Alright, Daymond.
Would you be willing
to go to 15%?
♪♪
The reason I'm doing this
is because I believe in you
and I think
there's a social mission to it.
Because sometimes I have to
bring in other licensing agents,
and then
I got to split that.
I'm gonna stick on the 20%.
And you're willing to lead
these licensing efforts,
get on the phone, help ‐‐
Yeah, and you know what?
If I don't get it,
you still have your company.
Okay.
We'll take your deal.
Yep!
‐Yeah! Mazel tov!
‐Yay!
[ Party horn honks,
cheers and applause ]
[ Laughs ]
Beautiful, beautiful.
Thank you much.
Thank you.
Alright. You got it.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Hey, thank you, man.
Gonna educate some kids.
Love: This is great!
Congratulations, guys.
Good luck, you guys.
‐Thank you.
‐Thank you all very much.
‐Congrats, guys.
‐Good luck.
Johnston: So, now that we got
Daymond on board,
we're gonna be able to
scale so much quicker.
We're really gonna be able to
do what our mission is ‐‐
to make learning
fun for every child.
And, again, that's why
we named our company...
Together: Tanoshi!
♪♪
Narrator: In season 7,
Ann Crady Weiss and Dave Weiss
made a deal with Chris Sacca
for their smart changing pad,
Hatch Baby.
I love to get in early
in companies.
This is the opportunity to get
in early before we get there.
So...
Let's see how they're doing now.
♪♪
Dave:
After "Shark Tank" aired,
we sold out
of our first production run
and did a million dollars
in sales.
Ann: We realized that the smart
changing pad solved a real need,
but there wasn't
a huge market for it,
so we targeted
the next big issue
for children,
which is sleep.
We developed Rest,
the night‐light,
sound machine,
and time‐to‐rise device.
Because of the success
of Rest,
we've done more than
$40 million in sales
since "Shark Tank."
Insufficient sleep has become
a public‐health epidemic,
so we decided to focus
the entire company
on helping everyone
to get good sleep.
Today, we're announcing
our first product
to help adults.
It's called Restore.
It talks to me. It leads me
through a guided meditation.
Yep.
What I love about
Restore is it's taken
all of the best science
and technology
and research about sleep
and helps you wake up feeling
as refreshed as you ever have.
Hey!
Hi.
I'm here to present
you guys
with USA TODAY's reviewed.com
CES Editors' Choice Award.
[ Laughs ]
So here you go.
Alright!
Wait. No way.
Congratulations.
Yeah. Absolutely.
To win an award
as one of the top 10
products at CES,
I mean, that was
a legit surprise today.
I had no idea that was coming.
What that tells me
is this thing
might even be bigger
than we had hoped.
Check it out!
Four years ago,
we were in Las Vegas at CES
in a long audition line
for "Shark Tank."
Today, we are dead‐set
on being
a multibillion‐dollar company
that helps everyone
to get good sleep.
Sacca: The future
for Hatch is limitless,
and I have no doubt this will be
one of the biggest companies
in the history of "Shark Tank."
Eat your heart out,
every other Shark
who passed on this deal.
Together: Hatch!
Narrator: Next into the Tank
is a product line
that utilizes data
in a unique way.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
My name is Ming Zhao.
I'm from San Francisco,
California.
I'm here to seek $500,000
for 5% equity
in my company.
Here it comes.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Sharks, what is
the one thing
that we all search
and pay a lot of money for?
The youth of our skin.
The problem is,
most beauty companies
box us into four
crude categories ‐‐
dry, oily, sensitive, normal ‐‐
even though our skin
is really complex,
dooming us into an endless cycle
of expensive trial and error.
That's why I took matters
into my own hands
to change the skin‐care industry
once and for all.
Introducing PROVEN skin care.
Using artificial intelligence
and cutting‐edge science,
we create a personalized
and effective skin‐care regimen
engineered for your skin
and your lifestyle.
To assess your skin,
simply log on to our website
to fill out your free
three‐minute
Skintelligence quiz.
Questions cover everything
from your skin concerns
to your stress levels
to your locality
and even uncovers
your pollution levels.
Then, using our award‐winning
Skin Genome Project database,
our scientists create your own
PROVEN 3 skin‐care routine ‐‐
a personalized cleanser,
a personalized night cream,
and a personalized day SPF,
all packed with the right
powerhouse ingredients for you.
At PROVEN, we're using science,
technology,
and hundreds
of ingredient combinations
to create the product
that works for you.
Sharks, it is inevitable
that artificial intelligence
will be the future
of flawless skin,
so who is ready to shake up
this industry with me?
And this is samples?
That's right.
So, based on what we know
about you, Sharks,
we've created products that
are personalized to you.
PROVEN is for men,
as well?
That's right. We have ‐‐ About
20% of our customers are men.
So, Daymond.
Yes.
You travel a lot for your
speaking engagements.
Yeah.
So we put in ingredients to
help protect your skin
from the dry cabin air.
Lori, you're on TV,
putting on, taking off
makeup every day,
so we put in ingredients
to help your skin
protect your skin barrier.
Kevin, Ontario has
really hard water,
so we put in citrus ingredients
to cut down on
the mineral deposits.
Anne, as a tech entrepreneur in
front of your computer screen,
phone screens all day,
so we put in ingredients
to help protect your skin
from the digital pollution,
HEV, and blue light.
Mark, Dallas actually
has really polluted air,
so we put in ingredients to
help protect your skin
from the environmental
pollution.
Thank you.
So, when you invest
in PROVEN skin care,
you're actually investing in a
technology‐first CPG company.
The database is called
the Skin Genome Project.
It is the largest
beauty database in the world,
and it has won MIT's AI
Technology of the Year Award.
But this is just the beginning,
so we're going to create
this new category
of personalized CPG
and be the category killer.
Ming, the MIT database
you referenced,
I assume, if I started
Mr. Wonderful Skin Care,
I could also access
that data, right?
No, it's proprietary to us.
We built it ourselves, and
we won the award ourselves.
Can you explain what
that is, this Skin Genome?
So, what we've done
is we've taken
all the available information
that is out there ‐‐
more than 20 million
consumer reviews,
more than 4,000
clinical research papers ‐‐
gathered all of that,
made sense of it,
and then made insights
and actions out of it.
In this case, the first one
is creating
our own personalized
skin‐care line.
So your technology
essentially
is going through all
the different reviews
that are out there
in the publications
and then synthesizing that
into novel insights?
That's right.
But then there's not actually
any genetics or anything.
Right now, there is not.
With the genetic
information ‐‐
I was getting excited.
Can you explain
novel insights?
Sort of a novel ‐‐
like a brand‐new kind of idea
or, you know, discovery.
So, our novel insight
is trying to understand
for different people,
different backgrounds,
different genetics,
under different environments,
different lifestyles,
what ingredients work well
for this subsegment of
the population versus another.
PROVEN is a brand
in the brutally competitive
skin‐care market,
of which
there are massive players.
Mm‐hmm.
Now, you have to
explain that story,
'cause nothing explains
what you just said.
That's gonna cost a fortune
to do that.
The skin science is what
we always call
kind of the voodoo science.
There's a lot of money
in this space,
but I haven't seen a lot of
really rigorous studies.
Very little science.
Have you ever heard
of PROVEN before?
No.
Zhao: That is exactly
what we're doing.
Starting with the database,
we then partner
with the head of dermatology
at Stanford University
to then actually distill
from the data
what are things that
he's seen as clinical research.
I have no idea what
you're talking about.
[ Laughter ]
What'd you say?
Let's go to sales.
$500,000 for 5% imputes
a $10 million value,
so I'm so excited
about your sales.
They're gonna be great.
‐Sure. [ Laughs ]
So, we were in our beta trial
for two months
earlier this year.
We gained $110,000 in sales.
Where were you selling?
And from what channel?
We were selling mostly
through digital channels,
through Facebook.
Facebook ads.
How much did you spend
to get
that $110,000 in sales?
So, we spent about
$90,000 to get to ‐‐
Okay.
You spent $90,000
to get $110,000?
That's right.
‐Okay. Then what happened?
‐Ooh.
And then, four weeks ago,
we relaunched a new website
with new branding.
Right.
And this month,
we're also on track
to do about $65,000.
I'm really working
with this.
I forgot to mention one thing
that you would love.
I've been taking anger
management, so...
[ Laughter ]
I forgot to mention one thing
you would love.
We also have a licensing
agreement for $3.5 million.
$3.5 million?
That's right,
to use our technology.
They want us to create an
adjacent category database
in the baby‐care space.
That's interesting.
If you really have something
proprietary with data
that you can sell other large
players in the skin space
and you can get
$3.5 million license deals,
Mr. Wonderful is your man.
But this business,
the chance that you will get
share in this space is so small.
It is so competitive, they will
crush you like cockroaches.
So that's a huge ‐‐
Greiner: How do you feel
about that, Ming?
Because we have
greater ambitions.
We're trying to be a
technology‐enabled CPG company,
and how many of those
can you think of?
None.
Yeah, but, Ming,
I have been pitched
at least six AI‐driven
cosmetic companies
in the last six months.
Yeah.
But did they win MIT's AI
Technology of the Year Award?
[ Laughs ]
Do they have any proof?
Just 'cause you
win an award ‐‐
I mean, you know
how many times ‐‐
And it's been proven
and tested out by many, and it's
been seen by many sci‐‐
John: Ming, while we're still
on the numbers, though,
let's just go down
the numbers.
Yeah.
So, okay, how much money
have you raised?
We've raised $6 million.
Ohh!       Ohh!
Ohh!                        Ohh!
There you go!
Wow.
‐Yippee‐yi‐yo‐yi‐yay!
‐Yeah!
This story is very unusual.
Let's take your sales
this year.
Let's just be
the most optimistic
we can be about PROVEN.
Give it to me.
We're projecting to do
$3 million, the fiscal year.
Wow.
O'Leary: Your customer
acquisition
is the cost of sales.
You make $110,000 in sales,
you spend $90,000.
It's almost one‐to‐one.
So, you don't care about that,
except you got to raise
more dough.
Right.
Next year,
on the $3 million...
‐Mm‐hmm.
‐...you think you'll break even?
Um, not yet.
We'll break even
the year after.
Cuban: So, wait.
So, effectively,
on your next year's
$3 million,
you are planning
on spending
$2 million or so
in advertising, correct?
That's right.
Okay.
So you're buying
your sales.
So, it's one thing to say
"My technology is amazing,"
but when you do that,
there should be
customer referrals.
You're saying, effectively,
that you're not expecting
anything from your existing
customer base,
because you're having
to buy all your sales.
That's actually not true.
It's a business decision
we're making
to keep on experimenting with
new channels, new methodology.
If we want to be profitable
next year, we can be.
So, Ming, um, so,
I'm really not
in the skin‐care stuff,
you know?
My mommy gave me
some great skin for my birthday.
[ Laughter ]
You know, a little chocolate
and everything.
It's amazing.
So I'm not gonna
waste your time.
I'm out.
Thank you, Daymond.
Look, Ming, the AI stuff
doesn't add up to me.
I don't think that there's
a lot of organic growth
that's built into this,
so for those reasons,
I'm out.
Thank you, Mark.
I've spent actually a decent
amount of time in this space.
My company, 23andMe,
we've actually done
a number of partnerships looking
at the genetics of skin care.
I absolutely believe
the world is coming
where everyone out there
is gonna have
personalized skin care,
but, again,
the data's not there yet.
Mm.
So for those
reasons, I'm out.
Thank you.
Listen, Ming, I think
you have a good idea,
but I think it's just
way too early for me.
You are really just
out of the gates.
You've already
taken in $6 million.
And it's gonna be
a long time
before I would
see back my money.
I'm sorry. I'm out.
[ Sighs ]
Ming, I thank you very much
for coming here today
because
you are living proof
that my anger‐management
training is working.
[ Laughter ]
Because what I wanted to do
is shred you to pieces.
This valuation
is absolutely ridiculous.
But here we are,
and the answer is...
no.
I'm out.
Ming, it's very important
that you leave now.
Alright.
Thank you very much.
‐Thank you.
‐Good luck, Ming.
‐Good luck, Ming!
‐Good luck.
Zhao: I feel like, at the
beginning of any innovation,
people don't understand.
There are always gonna be
nonbelievers and naysayers,
but that's not going to faze me.
I'm gonna keep doing
what I'm doing.
I was expecting that, you know?
Having watched so much
"Shark Tank,"
I actually think his
anger‐management training
is working.
[ Laughs ]
♪♪
Narrator:
Next up is a product
designed to engage kids
in learning.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
My name is Laura Boccanfuso.
I'm from
Columbia, South Carolina,
and I'm asking for
a $300,000 investment
for a 10% stake in my company,
Van Robotics.
Sharks, times have changed
when it comes to the way
students learn.
Kids have basically grown up
around technology,
and they definitely don't
just rely on textbooks
to help them
with school anymore.
The fact is, kids expect more.
Attention spans are shorter,
and by the time they graduate
from 12th grade,
U.S. students, only 25% of them
test proficient in math.
Yikes!
The need has never been greater
to find new and improved ways
to help students learn
and retain information.
So, a few years ago, I decided
to take my experience
helping kids by building tech
to create ABii,
the smart robot tutor.
ABii:
Hi, there, Sharks.
[ Laughs ]
Boccanfuso: ABii delights kids
with fun social interactions
that keeps them engaged
and builds confidence
through every lesson.
My name's ABii,
and I just love helping kids
ace their classes at school.
ABii is transforming
how students learn
through the power of
artificial intelligence.
She not only
tracks performance,
but also attention
to ensure
that she adapts every lesson
for every student every time.
What can I say?
I'm just that good.
ABii also delivers
national standards‐aligned
lessons
to make sure that kids
stay on track.
With her innovative way
of tutoring,
ABii is changing the future for
millions of kids everywhere.
So, tell me, Sharks,
who's ready to fuse
education and technology
to create a whole new world
of learning?
Wow. Amazing.
Truly unbelievable.
Oh, go on.
But, seriously, Sharks,
who's in?
Kevin, they made
a doll out of you.
[ Laughs ]
O'Leary: Well...
I think she said
ABii was a she.
She is a she.
Thank you.
You're welcome.
Very light.
So, I'd love to show you
how ABii works,
if you're ready to
see it in action.
Great.
Roll it.
It's Earl's first day,
but he's having a super‐hard
time paying attention.
Mark is sitting at
the back of the class,
launching spitballs
at Earl's head.
Luckily,
Earl's new friend, Anne,
is sitting right behind Earl,
and she is blocking
a lot of the spitballs.
If Mark shoots 23 spitballs
but only 7 actually hit Earl,
how many did Anne block?
Oh, phooey.
You missed that one.
Not to worry.
We'll do more examples together
in directed practice.
In the meantime,
let's celebrate with a dance.
[ Upbeat music plays ]
So, obviously, that's
an abbreviated lesson,
but I wanted to show you
at least
how the screen
and the robot
actually interact together,
presenting
important information.
So, are you already
selling this?
These are the first three
commercial versions
that we have hot off
the manufacturing press.
We do have some presales.
We have about $140,000
in presales
as of the last three months.
Is it a Kickstarter?
No, actually,
through e‐mails,
cold e‐mails, word of mouth,
and basically a grant that we
got from the Department of Ed
that is allowing us
to have 20 to 25 schools
across the state of
South Carolina with robots.
I spent nine years
in this space,
in math and reading scores,
with Reader Rabbit
at The Learning Company ‐‐
"Carmen Sandiego,"
"Oregon Trail."
Advancing math scores
is a big deal.
Do you have any data that shows
you've advanced math scores
in testing for kids?
Yes. Actually, we did
an alpha pilot last year
with about 220 students.
And so we had
67% of the students
actually improve
their math proficiency
on two math skills
during that pilot.
Laura, what's your background?
Are you a teacher? Are you ‐‐
I'm not a teacher.
I had a love for education,
I had a love for technology,
so I got a PhD in
computer science
and engineering.
With what focus?
With robotics,
social‐robotics focus.
Is your plan for ABii to only
sell into the school system,
or is this going to be
a consumer product
for parents to buy?
So, yes to both ‐‐
first with the school systems,
with the after‐school programs
and then eventually for
the direct‐to‐consumer sales.
What does ABii cost?
The commercial version of
ABii is $999 for schools.
‐$999?
‐Wow.
‐$999 for schools.
‐Yeah.
‐Oh, my goodness!
‐Wow.
Yes, but it comes with
all the curriculum ‐‐
third, fourth, and fifth grade.
It's only $599 for home use.
What does it cost
to make an ABii?
$250, delivered.
Wow, that's expensive!
Yeah, ooh.
Yeah.
I think sometimes,
with something like this,
it gets very complicated.
What are your top three
selling features?
ABii accelerates learning
for students
that have difficulty with
attention.
Accelerates learning.
What's number two?
Number two is it
breaks down barriers.
So, a lot of students
have confidence issues
in the classroom
when they are asked a question
and they don't understand.
They're afraid to speak up.
So, what was number three?
Parents tell us that
they have trouble
motivating their students
to do math homework,
and when they sit down
with ABii,
they feel like there is
a sentient little robot
that is paying
attention to them,
that is part of their
learning journey.
So, I get that. Alright.
I take you at your word
that it works,
but it's so brand‐new.
I'm not really sure how
you're going to be received
or what your
competition is,
because I know there
are others out there.
And for those reasons,
I'm out.
Cuban: Laura.
Thank you, Lori.
If my fourth grader is sitting
right in front of it
and it's interacting,
following the courseware,
what data and how is it
collecting that data?
We're collecting correct
and incorrect answers.
We're collecting
timing on screens.
We're also collecting attention.
How does it know?
That's also being recorded.
We look at the head orientation,
and then we know
that that head orientation
corresponds
to where the screen is.
Now we're getting into what
makes it unique, right?
Now we start to understand
what differentiates you
from a little Teddy bear
sitting there.
Sure.
Let me just jump in.
So, I love the education space,
but, for me, with 220 students
who have used it so far
and with the competitive space,
you know,
there's so many companies
that are out there right now
trying to bridge ‐‐
Who is doing this?
There's a lot just on the iPad,
you know, or on your computer.
I feel like it's pretty early.
I'm out.
Okay. Sorry to hear that.
It took me nine years
to get "Oregon Trail"
into 70% of the schools.
And there hasn't been
a successful company
to play
an educational product
that advances test scores
in consumer and school
since The Learning Company.
There's never been
another one
because these markets
are so different now.
Let me just throw in one
more thing and interject.
I understand the sales cycle.
I'm a fighter, you know?
No, I get it. I get it.
I was a stay‐at‐home mom
with three kids
before I decided to go back and
get my PhD in computer science.
This is the tip of the iceberg
you see here.
We've got already schools
signed up galore.
They want the empirical data.
We've got Boys & Girls Clubs
signed up,
already purchased their robots
so they can participate
in the study.
This is not something
that you see with apps.
It's ‐‐ It's more ‐‐
It doesn't happen.
Laura, it's more that
"Do I want to go back
to those days?"
We did $850 million
in consumer
and 80 in the schools,
and I spent 90% of my day
worrying about
the school business.
It's brutal.
Sure.
And I just ‐‐
I can't go back.
It's a segue.
It's like going back
to Hell for me.
So...
[ Laughs ]
When did you ever leave?
I can't do it.
I'm out. I'm out.
I'm out.
I'm in
the curriculum space.
I have a digital curriculum,
interactive.
When I tried to sell it
to the schools,
they couldn't care less,
because they already have
their systems,
and to echo what
Kevin's saying, it's brutal.
It takes
just such a long time.
And you want to do
two different things.
And I believe in
what you're doing.
I just don't want to take that
long ride with you, so I'm out.
Look,
I disagree with Kevin.
If you have a better mousetrap
that is so phenomenally better,
right, people will beat a path
down to your door.
Sure.
But you haven't shown me
something that's gonna say
"When I walk in the door
and put my name on ABii,
people are gonna say 'Wow.'"
What is it that
you have or will have
that segregates you
from anybody
who can possibly consider
getting into this space?
So, when you sit down
and ABii recognizes
where you left off
and understands you
and knows that you like,
as a third grader,
a wiggle break
and not a stretch break,
for example,
and the robot,
every time you log into it,
knows more about you,
you establish
a social connection
that is really powerful.
Yeah, see, I just ‐‐
that's not enough, Laura.
That's not enough.
I'm sorry. I'm out.
Okay.
‐Good luck, Laura.
‐Thank you, Laura.
‐Good luck.
Thank you so much.
Appreciate it.
Good luck, Laura.
Boccanfuso: Kevin's feedback
about it being
a very long road,
I agree with 100%.
We need some disruptive
technology
to change the future
for our students.
They're worth it,
and I'll put in the time.
If it's 9 years,
if it's 19 years, I'm in.
♪♪